hi there steve coffman here
today i want to talk about and i want to
hear from you about why you study
languages and i'm going to tell you why
i study languages
before i get into that i want to ask a
question too
what is the preferred frequency for
these videos once a month once a week
once every two weeks twice a week i
would be interested in hearing from you
because that'll help me make up my mind
as to how frequently you know i should
be doing them
i'm falling a bit behind here i was
doing videos in different languages i've
been busy
i will get to an italian one
either this weekend or early next week
tomorrow i have to drive to whistler
which is about an hour and 15 minutes
from where i live
there is a three-day conference uh a
lumber conference lumber buyers are
coming from all over the world so i'm
going to be going up there to meet
people
customers and hopefully new customers
so i was just thinking to myself you
know i'll be driving up there and it's a
spectacular drive surrounded by
snow-capped mountains here in in august
september it's it's beautiful
uh but the whole way up i will be
listening to
probably this
is an italian novel written in the 19th
century about events in italy
in the uh 17th century it's sort of the
classic novel in italian
this vid this audio by the way is by il
naratore who is a tremendous uh audio
narrator for italian you can look him up
on the internet ilnaratore.com
perhaps the outstanding
uh audiobook that he's done that i've
enjoyed is pinocchio where he does the
different characters in pinocchio it's
spectacular by the way
both e promesis posey and pinocchio the
texts are available on link
with librivox audio but the audio done
by il naratore is is well worth paying
more for to listen to it's spectacular
so i'm already looking forward to
driving up to whistler listening to ipro
messi sposey which i listened to
seven or eight years ago when i at a
previous sort of
period of concentration on italian
uh also here well
driving around in vancouver because i in
one way or another i'm in the car an
hour a day
uh and so i went to find podcasts in
italian
and uh
raid
rai the red national radio uh
broadcasting network in in italy they
have a chain number two
which puts out podcasts fantastic
podcasts which i have now
uh subscribed to um
on you know through youtube or excuse me
through itunes
and i've been listening to podcasts
about
frederick the great of prussia there's
one on the history of la cucina of
cooking
uh there's one on on roman emperors
there's one on
charlemagne
so and what's interesting in all of this
is is you're listening to
uh the language you're learning and
you're you're learning so much about
different things in history but from a
different perspective
that i do i had a series on china as
well
and and of course
that's been my experience with all these
languages with the russian with the
czech with the romanian
why do i
you know learn these languages because
it's so much fun to
enter
this different world i listen i'm
following the moscow election in russia
in russian
i'm getting their perspective on the
syrian crisis
and
you know watch movies read books so to
me
my learning of languages i should add
too that i'm also reading because when i
go to bed i like to read so i'm reading
umberto eccos
de la rosa in italian so i got a lot of
italian stuff going it's just it's fun
it's so much fun so for me
i i must admit i am more made motivated
initially by
by being able to access the language
because if i think of the amount of time
you know that i have to enjoy
the language here in vancouver i can go
to an italian restaurant and i can chat
up the waiter maybe in italian that's
very brief
however
if i'm in my car for an hour going to
whistler and it'll be another hour
coming back and i'll be listening to
this
novel
and that's a lot of enjoyment that's a
lot of enjoyment i mean some people
would perhaps be more interested in what
kind of car they're driving to go up to
whistler me i have my seven year old
saab and it does me just fine
uh in fact you know it's it's easier
almost to control the the cds in that
car than in a
more modern sophisticated car with
modern cd players and stuff like that
but
the amount of time that i enjoy
basically listening and reading far
exceeds the amount of time that i am
able to spend speaking the language and
i think that's not unusual i could be
wrong but
people who learn the language in order
to say a few things
because they're
maybe have an opportunity to use it a
few times and then they're disappointed
and they didn't do so well
uh i'm not saying that that's not a
legitimate
reason to learn a language but if you if
you think of the time of enjoyment that
you're going to have
it seems to me that the amount of
enjoyment that we can have
listening to
you know podcasts or watching movies or
reading books
and gaining that different you know
perspective on
cultures or even on world events or on
history and cooking and so forth
that length of time is greater than the
amount of time we would have actually
engaging someone in the conversation
plus
if i invest all of that time in these
kinds of activities
then
when i go to speak i have a much better
background from which to improve my
speaking so eventually my speaking will
come along so it's not that i'm not
interested in speaking but in my own
case my motivation in learning russian
and learning czech and learning italian
and brushing up my german is all about
this access that i get to their world
but i do get the benefit that when i
then go to prague as i did or go to
berlin as i did fairly recently or
when i was with my wife in italy two
years ago then we can of course we can
speak but anyway i just want to point
out that that i am tremendously
motivated and i get great enjoyment i
mean i have i don't know how many books
i have in italian that i haven't yet
read
i was counting my uh audio cds up there
in different languages russian czech
german swedish i mean i've got to have
i don't know 500 cds some of which are
mp3 cds
uh some of which i've listened to i mean
i've got a
i am never bored and you know after i
finish my italian period then i'm going
to do some swedish because i don't want
to just jump in and do a video i want to
kind of enjoy
experiencing that swedish thing and i've
got a lot of swedish historical
audiobooks that i bought
and books
so that's my enjoyment now i might be a
bit unusual in that regard uh other
people maybe they like chatting on the
internet
finding language partners on the
internet uh reading different language
blogs which i also do by the way and so
there are many different reasons why
people learn languages or some people
need it for their job
or they are you know moved to a
different country so there could be many
many
uh reasons why people learn languages i
just wanted to share with you
my reason for learning languages
and so i look forward to hearing from
you about why you learn languages and
also
any comments as to what your preferred
frequency is for these videos thank you
for listening bye for now